Hi everybody,
I'm Sze-Chuan Suen.
I'm a faculty member
at the Industrial and
Systems Engineering at USC.
And today I'm very pleased to
be talking to you about some of
the projects that I've done on
tuberculosis or TB in India.
So TB now kills more
people than HIV worldwide.
Which is surprising
to a lot of people.
And most of my work
in focused on India.
In the contexts of
Indian Tuberculosis because
about a quarter of the worlds
cases reside here.
And besides many of the drug
sensitive or DS cases in TB.
One of the problems facing India
is a growing number of drug
resistant tuberculosis cases of
which about 3% of all cases are.
So drug resistant TB will
happen when patients undergo
antiboditic therapy but they
don't finish their regiments or
can also occur because
of direct transmission.
So I'll talk about both of
those pathways today and
the problem that drug resistant
or DRTB presents is really that
it requires treatment with
second line antibiotics which
can be more costly and can be
more toxic to the patient.
And can also be very
difficult to diagnose because
these patients will present with
the same symptoms as a drug
sensitive TB patient.
So I'm gonna talk about some of
the work that I have done in
these area.
Obviously there is a lot
of projects here, so
I'm not gonna talk
about all of them.
But I welcome questions
on any of them.
I won't talk about this Gates
Foundation Model Comparison that
I've done in the past, and Ryan
here will be talking a little
bit more about the TB outreach
resource allocation model
towards the end of this talk.
And Cara will introduce some of
the topics that we have been
talking about for collaboration
on predicting treatment default.
But to move on to some of
the overview of what I've done
before.
One of the models that
I originally built was
an individual level
simulation on predicting drug
resistance TB
problems prediction.
So in this model, we followed
individuals from birth until
death moving through
different health states,
whether a latent drug sensitive
or drug resistant TB,
active disease,
as well as treatment.
And we wanted to make this
model as detailed as possible.
And since we were modelling
Indian Tuberculosis, we included
many of the treatment
options that are available in
India such as private treatment,
as well as the one
that's offered by the federal
government, public treatment for
first line,
as well as second line therapy.
So this is a pretty busy slide
just to guide you through it.
We looked at for
instance patient undergoing
first line therapy.
We looked into the literature
for the RNTCP or
the public funding program
that treats tuberculosis.
It gives us six months of the
treatment for each patient and
there were monthly risks of
death and default that we
incorporated into the simulation
so that we would accurately
model how patients behaved
on these treatment programs.
As well as things like drug
resistant testing which patients
undergo in first line
therapy at around month four.
And they could exit off of
treatment, either successfully
treated or with active or latent
tuberculosis if they default or
failed from treatment.
And so
we wanted to be realistic and
capture these patterns
as much as possible.
In addition, we wanted to
include demographic and
behavioral factors and so
a lot of these were informed how
tuberculosis is transmitted.
So for instance, transmission
rates varied by age and
reflected household compositions
within the simulation.
Transition rates depended on
natural history, and age, and
competing mortality risks also
dependent on age and sex.
And in the simulation we
had treatment uptake and
adherence and success that
varies by age and sex,
as well as by the time and what
time it was in the simulation.
So for instance,
we had the model Burn In so
that our demographics
would stabilize.
So our patient population that
we simulated within the model
would reflect that age
stratifications that we saw in
India, and
that was very important to
get the population correct.
And we also had population
growth within the simulation
because we know the demographics
within India are changing
over time.
And so these are match
to both historical and
projections of Indian
population growth for
the United Nations
Population Division.
Over time we had the federal
treatment program ramp up and so
in the simulation we had
more and more patients,
have access to tuberculosis
treatment over this period.
And over that time, we can see
that the simulation estimates
here depicted in red are very
similar to those that
were given by the WHO from this
period for both problems and
incidents of tuberculosis.
So we can be more confident that
the simulation is performing
in an accurate way.
We also had second line therapy
ramp up over the appropriate
period in the simulation.
So which now we can do
projections about the future to
inform us about how
the TB prevalence and
epidemic are going to
behave in the future.
And over this period,
we see circular trends
such as population aging
which we would expect to
see over this period.
So now we have this really neat,
cool simulation.
What can we do with it?
So one of the interesting things
that we could do was to look at
how people acquire
drug resistant TB.
And this is a problem that you
can't actually go and ask people
about because people don't know
where they got tuberculosis.
And so, for these cases of
drug resistant TB which
the Government of India
is very keen on reducing,
we could split them apart in
transmission generated case.
So people got coughed on and
they acquired drug resistant TB,
versus those that were
rising because of failed or
incomplete treatment regiments.
And we see that over time, this
simulation will project that
a larger and larger proportion
of people are getting cases
directly through transmission.
And this has implications for
how we can treat drug-resistant
TB and how we can
interrupt the process of
people getting these diseases.
The second topic I'm going
to touch a little bit on
is looking at policy
prioritization and looking at
cost-effectiveness analysis
to inform policy decisions.
So for instance, the government
of India is planning to acquire
expensive new GeneXpert
diagnosis systems,
which allows for
more accurate TB diagnosis, and
this also very quickly
able to distinguish
between drug sensitive and
drug resistant tuberculosis.
Now these are very
expensive systems.
So we wanted to inform
the government about
how they should use them.
So one of the ways that we could
use them is to just use them for
drug resistant testing at
month number four in first
line therapy.
But we can also introduce these
systems for initial diagnosis.
So we wanted to look
at the costs and
the health impacts of doing
both of these polices.
And we compare them against
institutional reforms
like public private mixes or PPM
programs which the government of
India is also considering doing.
Where private clinic patients
are referred to public clinics,
because public clinics generally
have more oversight and
more informed doctors that
are looking specifically for
TB patients.
We also looked at combination
strategies of these different
policies.
And by informing the simulation,
the individual level simulation
with information about costs
as well as health outcomes,
we can form the cost
effective frontier for
all of the policies
that we considered.
Being able then to identify
the tradeoffs between health and
costs and tell the government
where there were inefficient
polices that were not lying
on that affected frontier.
And so this sort of analysis
can inform public policy
in terms of healthcare.
The last problem that I
want to touch on is about
when to test for
drug resistant tuberculosis and
this was solved
using a POMDP model.
So there are two tests that is
used for first line therapy.
Sputum Smear Tests or
SS Tests are very cheap but
they're also very inaccurate.
They have very low sensitivity
so they're very noisy, and
they also cannot detect
the disease strain.
So these types of tests which
are currently used give us
a very noisy estimate of whether
our patient has TB or not.
Drug Sensitivity Testing or
DST, which we'll
consider in the context of these
expensive GeneXpert systems,
are very expensive as
I've told you before, but
they're very accurate and they
can detect the disease strain.
So the question we asked here
was how we could use this noisy
test to identify which
patients need DST, and
when they should undergo DST?
So we want to have
high risk patients and
use that expensive but
very accurate test on them so
we can triage them into the
appropriate second line therapy.
Right now DST,
drug sensitive testing is
being done at month four, but
with this new technology It's
unclear whether or not we should
do it earlier or later in that
first line therapy treatment.
An so we wanted to find patients
specific DST times that would
provent unnecessary testing
which is high financial costs.
But we did don't want to do
it because it will accelerate
triage into appropriate
treatment for
those patients that did have
drug resistant tuberculosis.
Now recall only about 3%
of the TB cases in India,
have drug resistant TB.
So it's a pretty low population.
So we wanna focus on
these high risk patients
that we would be able to
identify using this test.
So just to give you
an overview of our palm DP,
at every month there would some
belief state that the physician
had about the patient,
whether or
not they were successfully
treated, whether they still had
drug sensitive TB or
had drug resistant TB.
They are then able to do three
actions, either DST that patient
using that expensive test
that's very accurate,
or have the patient continue
on treatment either with or
without a noisy test from
the spetum smear test.
The patient would undergo
treatment and if the physician
wanted to test the patient
receive a noisy positive or
negative test result from
the patient and then be able to
update their belief about
the patient's health state.
So this will continue for
the six months of TB treatment.
And we ran our palm DP in
order to find the result, and
we found that in fact it was
optimal to DST the patient had
initial diagnosis.
This is somewhat surprising
because there's very few number
of TB cases that have
drug resistant TB, and so
we would be unnecessarily
testing a lot of people,
which has high financial costs.
Now this is in fact driven
by TB transmission,
because those downstream costs
of further transmission,
identifying those people,
bringing them into treatment and
then treating them with second
line therapy was so high.
It was worth it to do that
unnecessary testing upfront.
So those are some of the topics
that I've done research on, and
Bryan will now talk about
TB outreach programs and
resource allocation.
>> Hi, everyone, so
my name is Bryan Wilder and I'll
be picking up with some recent
ongoing work with
tuberculosis in India.
So Sze already covered
the basic motivation here.
And the focus of this work is
how do we get more patients into
treatment for
tuberculosis in the first place,
because treatment is
provided for free, right?
So this is one of
the major bottlenecks.
And a common strategy for this
is outreach campaigns, right.
So, patients either don't know
tuberculosis symptoms, or
they don't know
the treatment is available,
and so the government
will conduct these
advertising campaigns, right, to
raise awareness and get people
into treatment when they think
that they may have TB symptoms.
And so this is just one example
of such an advertisement, and
there are many others, right.
And there are many ways that we
could structure these campaigns.
So, maybe the ad on the far left
here is aimed at parents of
small children,
the one in the middle is aimed
at sports fans, and so on.
So there are many
different demographic
groups that I can think
of advertising to.
And I only have a limited amount
of money with which to conduct
these campaigns, and so
the question that we're
interested in in this work is
given that I have this limited
budget how should I divide it up
between different demographic
groups in the population?
So who are the sorts of people
that I should focus the most
resources on in order to have
the greatest impact on TB rates
overall?
So in this work we'll give
sort of a brief overview, so
we introduced an SIS style
multiagent model of disease
spread.
And then in this model we even
algorithm called DOMO to compute
neuro optimal
resource allocations.
So a division of a finite budget
between different demographic
groups in the population.
So we're able to both give
theoretical guarantees for
this approach and then we also
conduct a data-driven evaluation
and simulation of the policies
produced by our algorithm.
And we find that by using
its recommendations
compared to a extrapolation
of status quo policies
we convert thousands of cases of
tuberculosis each year in India.
So as a brief overview, the
style of model that we have here
in this work is
a compartmental model so
we have different demographic
groups in this case
a segmentation of
the population by age.
And so there is a finite
population of agents having
these groups are born they age
they die they move between
groups and so on.
And so, and they also
transmit the disease so
there are some agents
that are infected and
agents in each group
have at some rate with
which they come into contact
with agents in other groups.
And if you come into contact
with an infected agent then you
yourself become infected.
So then when we think
about optimal targeting of
resources in this model there
are a number of challenges.
So you might say well
why don't I just
target the groups that have
the most infected agents, right?
That's where I'll sort
of get the most bang for
my buck in terms of
targeting advertisements.
But this doesn't work on its
own because maybe some groups
are more important for
between groups, right?
So if there is a particular age
range that is in contact with
lots of others, then even
if they don't have as many
infected agents in
terms of sure number,
maybe you just focus on
advertisements there
to reduce prevalence
rates down the stream.
But that on its own also isn't
sufficient, right, because that
would suggest, okay, maybe I
should look at contact patterns
and just target advertisements
at the groups that have the most
sort of contact with others.
But that also isn't optimal
because you have to think
about the demographics of
the population and how
things will evolve over time as
people age and move and so on.
Then complicating all of this
right, these difficulties and
what the optimal
strategy might be.
There's just lots of things
you don't know about
the problem in practice.
So in particular for
TB in India we found initial
prevalence rates, so the number
of infected agents in each
group are really uncertain
because a lot of patients don't
report to approved
treatment facilities.
And we also don't
know these contact patterns
between the groups.
So I don't really
know what is the rate
at which people who
are 20 years old
come into contact with people
who are 40 years old, right?
These are just things that we
don't really have good data on.
And so, I'm not going to go
into really any detail about
the algorithm here.
But the gist of it is that
we construction optimization
problems, or modelling
these different tradeoffs.
And so our approach to
the DOMO algorithm has sort of
a principled way of deciding on
the optimal treatment in a way
that accounts for the different
sorts of the demographic and
epidemiological factors in the
problem and also accounts for
the incompleteness of our data,
right, so it solves a stochastic
problem where we have
only uncertain knowledge.
So we only have sort of
distributions over what many of
the parameters of
the problem might look at.
And so
we conduct an evaluation and
simulation of the policies
produced by DOMO.
And so we use existing data from
a variety of sources right?
So government reports,
the RNTC program,
the epidemiological
literature and so on.
And then given that there's
still uncertainty in the data
then we construct appropriate
sort of distributions over
the parameters that
we don't know about.
And here as a brief snap shot of
the results so we're comparing
our algorithm to, so we compared
it to our range to different
characteristics and strategies
that you could think of for
the problems and
there's a few of them here.
And so these strategies
are you know what if you just
focus on the groups with
the highest prevalence rates.
What if you extrapolate from
the status quo treatment rates,
right, just focus your resources
in proportion to what's being
done now.
And lastly,
what quote high degree,
so if you focus on the groups
that have the highest amount of
contact with others.
And we find that our algorithm
can substantially improve on
these existing sorts of policies
and advert thousands of persons
with tuberculosis each year
compared to these strategies.
So this is where we're at right
now with a model and algorithm
for targeting TB average
campaigns, we have promising
results but this is very
much an outgoing project and
I hope to talk to you many about
in this area during breaks.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you so much, so if you
have any clarification questions
while the next speaker sets up?
Just ask a quick question.
>> I have one, so one, at the
end of your talk you mentioned
that the DST in the initial
stage is the best.
Does it mean you have to do for
every patient or
is there any filter at all you
can do to suspect that someone
has drug resistant TB?
>> So in the context of our
model we assumed that the only
information that the physician
had was national prevelance
levels, so 3% of the patients
would be drug resistant,
and everybody else would
be drug sensitive.
And so we assume that everybody
would be exposed to DST in
that case and it was still
cost effective to do it.
So our objective function
there was taking into
account of both costs and
health outcomes.
And if you looked for
a long enough time at Horizon,
it was in fact cost saving
because of the saved costs from
not having to treat
downstream infection.